we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p that
voicemail number is open to you 24 hours
a day doesn't matter where i am doesn't
matter where you are if you've got skype
google voice a regular phone whatever
you can call to 192 david p and leave a
voicemail troy york left a voicemail
yesterday and i'm gonna play it for you
in a second if you're not familiar with
troy york troy york is a truly a
longtime listener of the david pakman
show and what's particularly interesting
about troy org is that every single one
of his voicemails are hugely negative
hugely critical of me and of the show
the shows a disaster were just all
horrible but you can tell that he
listens to and watches every episode
because he knows everything that's
happening on the show so something is
keeping troy york here let's take a
listen to what he had to say last night
early this morning david pakman you are
stupider than a pancake you people on
the left are upset because you you rang
one the most corrupt political insider
candidate of all time and expected to
win in the landslide in trunk upset your
plans you're correct
racial identity bankers you belong in
the country that's free-falling and
declining and it's not america but
that's your native Argentina the people
dropping Venezuela as well as the lose
their country and youth program sucks
yeah yeah this is so funny because none
of this stuff is coherent in any way
like in number one the peso in Argentina
has been falling significantly there's a
big currency problem there what that has
to do with the quality of the David
Pakman show
I don't know saying that I am in any any
way connected to the pushing of Hillary
Clinton to be the Democratic nominee I
voted for Bernie in the primary so I I
was not yes when it came to election day
I was not voting for Donald Trump but I
was not somebody
for Hillary to be the nominee I was
pushing for Bernie to be the nominee and
then lastly can't they stop talking
about Venezuela like I have a critic of
Venezuela the Left there's a lemonis
contingent of the left that hates me
because I criticized Venezuela so I
don't even get the point of mentioning
Venezuela in the voicemail but you know
what I don't get the point of a lot of
troy york's voicemail so that's probably
not hugely surprising to you on the
bonus show today Sean Hannity expects
Donald Trump to fire robert muller after
hurricane florence comes and goes we
have a new study which suggests that
full fat dairy
not that skim stuff or that low fat
stuff full-fat dairy may boost longevity
and health and we will also talk about
the woman who flipped off Donald Trump's
motorcade a while ago don't even
remember what it was
she's now running for office would you
vote for her and would you do it on the
basis of her having flipped off Trump I
think the answer to the second question
for me is an obvious indefinite no but
we will talk about what she has going on
get access to the world-famous bonus
show Pat will be joining me on today's
bonus show from Boston David Pakman show
headquarters headquarters for a few more
weeks we talked about that yesterday
ww join pakman.com coupon code vote soon
18 is available you can also get instant
access to the bonus show by becoming a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show both options get you access and I
will speak to you in mere seconds on
that bonus show if you are a member or
patron